الجيش الاسرائيلي عبر حسابه على تويتر
مشاهد من قصف اهداف في قطاع غزه الليله
الماضيه وفاد الجيش بانه هاجم اهدافا
تابعه لحركه حماس ونفقا تحت الارض
ومواقع لتخزين الاسلحه ومجمعات عسكريه
هذا صحيح محمد نحن هنا امام
منزل
الشهيد الذي اعلنت عنه وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وهو من عائله ابو مبارك يبلغ
من العمر في الثامنه والخمسين من عمره
بالتاكيد
واضح بان الغاره التي استهدفت مقرا
للتدريب لاحد فصائل المقاومه في هذه
المنطقه انما عندما استهدف هذا الموقع
تناثرت بعض الحجاره والشظايا جراء دك هذا
الموقع بعده صواريخ بشكل عنيف تطايرت احدى
هذه الحجاره والشظايا على احد هذه المنازل
على مقربه من المكان الذي نقف فيه وهي في
غالبيتها بيوت من الاسباست او او من الواح
الزنجو او الصاج وبالتالي عندما يعني
انهمرت على هذه المنطقه تسب في استشهاد
هذا المواطن الفلسطيني فضلا عن عدد من
الاصابات في مختلف الغارات التي شهدتها
قطاع غزه هذه المواقع العسكريه التي عاده
ما تكون قريبه نسبيا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين عاده ما تلجا الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه الى استهدافها في كل
موجات التصعيد التي رايناها حتى الان
وشاهدناها وقمنا بتغطيتها وايضا حتى في
موجه التصعيد الواحده في غالبيه المرات او
في كثير من المرات تلجا الطائرات الحربيه
الى استهداف ذات الموقع بعدد كبير من
الغارات والصواريخ وهو الامر الذي يحدث
اضرارا كبيره في مرات محدوده تتطاير هذه
الشظايا وهذه وهذا الحطام على منازل
المواطنين القريبه نسبيا من هذه
باعتبار ان قطاع غزه في نهايه المطاف هي
رقعه جغرافيه سهليه محدوده مملوءه
بالمنازل ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه وهو
الامر الذي يؤدي في كثير من المرات الى
حدوث اضرار في منازل المواطنين ووقوع بعض
الجرحى كما اعلنت وزاره الصحه في هذا
اليوم على سبيل المثال وقوع خمسه اصابات
وصفت بالطفيفه او الخفيفه نتيجه هذا
الحطام وتهشم بعض النوافذ بشكل عام
الغارات كانت عنيفه طالت عددا كبيرا من
مواقع المقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه في
المقابل المقاومه الفلسطينيه اطلقت عشرات
القذائف الصاروخيه على مناطق في منطقه
غلاف قطاع غزه بعض هذه القذائف تجاوزت
قليلا بعمق اكثر من 20 كيلو متر بمعنى
انها تجاوزت منطقه الغلاف بقليل وايضا كان
لافتا اطلاق قذائف ارض جو باتجاه الطائرات
التي شاركت في تنفيذ سلسله الغارات على
قطاع غزه ووفق البيانات المنفصله من كتائب
القسام وسرايا القدس التي تحدث عن اطلاق
هذا النوع من المضادات الارضيه
وكان لافتا ايضا محمد بان هذا الرد
بمجموعه كان كانت تصدر بيانات من غرفه
العمليات المشتركه بمعنى ان الموقف كان
متقنا بعد سلسله من الاجراءات من
المشاورات والاتصالات والاجتماعات توصلت
الفصائل الى هذا القرار بمعنى انه عدم
تفويت هذه الجريمه كما قالوا جريمه اغتيال
خضر عدنان في زنزانته وبالتالي يتوجب الرد
لكن كما يبدو فان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
اختارت ان ترد ضمن قواعد الاشتباك
المتعارفه اليها ولذلك كانت اولى رشيقات
الصاروخيه استهدفت منطقه غلاف غزه
وحتى الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا التزم بهذه
القواعد في غاراته